4-9 record at a 4.447 era the biggest
thing for brubaker over the last six
starts the ground ball rates down the
slugging's up and it's really been due
to the non-fastballs that he's been
throwing the fastball hasn't been quite
as effective and guys have been able to
jump on that off speed stuff a little
bit differently so hopefully you can get
that fastball going early today dubai
one strike delivery toy and that ball's
going to be put up in the air left
center field it'll be in runner's going
to go to third
good break and a base hit picked up by
alonso so the mets get added here in the
first inning nimmo taking off the easy
read gets to third davis heads to first
now the bases will be loaded there is an
opportunity for dominic smith
oh my goodness he gets it i mean i love
it just an absolutely bold bold and
beautiful pitch right there here's the
pitch
and a ground ball softly hit onto the
shortstop newman he'll flip it onto
first and brewmaker gets out of it
the mets strand the base is loaded and
the pirates come about in the bottom of
the first no score
taiwan walker takes the bound in the
bottom of the first inning and his
record he could have
11 wins at at the break 10 wins if he'd
had a little bit of more a little more
support but he has just been solid he
knows how to pitch great demeanor on the
mound he's a professional
he slaps one to left this is gonna be a
fair ball
nice piece of heading by default it's
gonna clang around in the left field
corner smith gets it in quickly it's a
double for defoe defoe at second with
one out and the met's trying to keep
this the score of this game swinging the
ground ball through the right side base
hit defoe's gonna be waved around third
conforto up with it from right the throw
home is late and he's in there it's an
rbi single for brian reynolds and the
pirates open with a one-nothing lead the
legend john nagowski and a line drive
he's done it again
what's going on with this guy
the dude and look at this
hora sends the runner he's safe
nickowski to third what's going on
all i've seen him hit is lion drives
he's a he's a special cat isn't he's a
machine and now they're loaded for
newman
they said go go go it's a fair ball it's
a fair ball oh my goodness
it's a fair ball do you believe this
it's still in play pirates score three
oh my gosh
we've seen it all now
we've seen it all
there goes rojas
he might not be the first he just bumped
the home plate up higher
let's see here we go
oh my gosh
touching the chalk touching oh he made
the he made the right call
that ball was on the job
one of the most bizarre plays you'll
ever see in your entire life
to his credit he got it right foul tip
and he struck him out vr is gone
brubaker with three strikeouts three-two
pitch dribbled toward second base fraser
waits on it has time he'll flip it onto
first it's a one two three inning in the
second for brubacher so this would be
pitch number 11 coming up
and he swings and lines one to the gap
in right center he turned around that
fastball and sends it near the wall cut
off on the backhand by conforto and
it'll be a double for gamel with one out
here in the second inning
and got him and he shakes his head yes
good pitch
nagowski shook his head yes after going
after that pitch and missed it and went
out of the strike zone there one up the
ladder on him one-two pitch is chopped
to the right side into the shift grabbed
by mcneil on the outfield grass he
throws to first so one hand and one left
for the pirates through two innings here
is alonzo picked up a base hit his first
time up runner on it first nobody out
one two he went could not hold up on
that slider down in the way strike three
and alonzo not happy
and that one is going to be grounded
into right field that'll be a base hit
on the way to third goes
nimmo in first and third
so mcneil delivers a single it's gonna
be an eight-game hit streak for mcneil
in first and third with two away smith
the strikeout victim his first time to
the plate
dominick goes after it down the line
fair ball
so the mets
needing to get it done due smith gets
the rbi nemo scores and it is a 6-1 ball
game brubaker ready in the pitch and a
swing at a high pop-up
out toward right
and polanco waiting for it to come down
he makes the catch two-handed that ends
the inning match pick up a run on two
hits strand two now two on nobody out
here on the fourth all it takes is one
rally here a three or four run inning to
put the mets right back into this game
puts that one up in the air he got a lot
of it way back hey goodbye home run
just what the match dated his first
career home run
pinch hitting
and he drives in three and makes it a
ball game as the pirate lead is cut to
six to four mousino bats here with one
out and one on it's down by two the
pitch breaking ball chops softly third
base side it's gonna be a tough play
they will not have a play
picked up by depot
no chance to get neato at first it's an
infield single
and now the mets have runners on first
and second with one out nito has his
second hit of the day reinhardter sets
in the 2-1 breaking ball hit to right
and well polanco though there he'll make
the catch
that is the second out
late swing and a miss he struck him out
he went back upstairs with a fastball
and he strikes out nimmo
stratton pitches his scoreless fifth
let's go
here's the 1-2
and a swing and a hard ground ball
hopping off the mound diving stop vr and
he can't come up with the ball to throw
out gamble so it'll be a base hit 1-2
pitch
chopped back over the mound near second
grab by vr steps on second crowds to
first for a double play to end the
inning and we'll move it on to the sixth
inning with the pirates leading six to
four left-handed batting dominic smith
do up smith one for three iran at first
baseball got in on him a little bit it
goes into the corner into right field
that is a fair ball bolanco going over
it again it will be a double making the
turn at third gonna bring him home as
the ball got away and he'll get a run
ball got bobbled on the relay and it is
a one-run ball game good heads up base
running mcneal
with the help of third base steve
sarcina and it's six to five pirates
have loaded the bases with nobody out
on the outside corner strike three call
frazier goes down looking not a guy who
strikes out a lot but a big strike out
there for luke
on the inside corner strike three call
defoe goes down looking
aaron loop with back to back strikeouts
hitting the edges of the plate with the
bases loaded here 0-2 on the way
reynolds he goes after it what a job by
luke fantastic work
0-1
then went outside on his slow roll
it's gonna stay on the grass and
alonso's on with the second hit we don't
often see pete alonso turn on the speed
but he does there and the one two from
bednar swing and a miss he struck him
out
97 above the zone bednar issues a
scoreless eighth and richard rodriguez
going for his third save in this seven
game uh series and the mets have their
lead off man on here in the top of the
ninth inning one ball one strike the
pitch
and porto it's a high fly ball deep
center field reynolds is back at the
wall and he's gone
the home run michael conforto gives the
mitch the lead a two-run homer and the
mets have come all the way back from a
six-nothing deficit they have taken a
seven to six lead here in the top of the
ninth so the save opportunity will go to
trevor may ball one strike the pitch
swinging a ground ball right side right
to alonso he takes it to the bag and the
mets win trevor may closes it out an
incredible comeback for the mets today